there's a cancer in the education system
students with this cancer are
two-and-a-half times more likely to fail
a grade they're less able to focus less
able to memorize and in a fundamental
affront to the purpose of Education this
cancer inhibits a student's ability to
create new brain cells it's not an
uncommon cancer the majority of American
students experience it to some degree by
the time they're teenagers and yet our
education system doesn't set aside the
resources to deal with this now before I
name this cancer I want to tell you why
I'm talking to you about it before I
came to the GSB I lived and worked in
downtown Detroit where I helped start a
coding bootcamp company I'm proud to say
that we trained hundreds of adults in a
new career path software development but
what bothered me at the time was that we
were turning away hundreds more and I
said looked at their applications I
realized we weren't turning him away
because they had bad attitudes and it
wasn't because they lacked the right
motivation instead they had been so
deeply under served by their K through
12 education that they were incapable of
learning what we had to teach so I
looked into the best analysis and
research to understand what is so wrong
with K through 12 and what I found was
that the culprit isn't teacher tenure
and it isn't because there aren't enough
iPads in the classroom instead it's this
cancer it's called childhood trauma and
there are many different types from
having a parent in prison to witnessing
domestic violence in the home to
experiencing emotional neglect to sexual
abuse but the common thread the real
definition of childhood trauma is this
it's the experience for a child repeated
over years of their safest relationships
undermined the people and environments
that should represent safety and
security instead become dangerous and
threatening now the impact of this
trauma is real people who experience it
are more likely to have heart disease
more likely to be depressed more likely
to commit suicide but one of the most
pervasive and yet least discussed
impacts of this is its impact on
learning and to help us understand
exactly what that might look like let's
think of a case study a student named
Shawn
let's say Shawn's dad is in prison and
as a result his mom works long hours to
make up for that financial burden when
she comes home from work she's exhausted
and emotionally unavailable for Shawn
let's say Shawn wakes up some mornings
to an empty house his mom's already
gotten to work and he's left wondering
if anyone is looking out for him now
what Shawn experiences these things his
body responds in the same way that all
of our bodies respond to stressful
events his breath gets short his heart
beats faster in his brain as it floods
with adrenaline and cortisol experiences
a fight-or-flight response it's
concerned with only one thing getting
Shawn out of the situation they can't
think any deeper than that and that's
where Shawn's learning gets affected
because every morning when Shawn goes to
school
it looks like he's leaving the cause of
his trauma at home but the effects stay
with him he may look like he's ready to
learn algebra or grapple with the big
questions of history but his mind has
become accustomed to responding to
trauma and that doesn't stop in the
classroom
his brain is physiologically incapable
of learning and his brain chemistry
becomes the barrier to a quality
education now a fight response in the
classroom might look like Shawn acts out
and is disruptive a flight response
might look like he's uninterested or
disengaged and if Shawn's at a school
that hasn't trained its teachers to
recognize these things as potential
symptoms of childhood trauma Shawn might
just be ignored as a problem child and
if he never gets to a school that is
prepared to understand what he's
struggling with he might get robbed of
an education that he deserves his very
future becomes a victim of his
now I know we're talking about the
education system here Child Protective
Services is supposed to stop this drama
from happening but what I think is so
critical to understand and the reason
why I'm standing here talking to you
today is that I think that schools have
a critical role to play in helping
students get the tools and resources
they need to overcome the impact of the
trauma they've already experienced I
think we need to redefine what we
consider a quality education it's not
enough to think of schools is simply
transmitting information I think schools
need to prepare the minds of the
students to absorb that knowledge
because it doesn't matter how fantastic
your curriculum is if you're trying to
teach students whose brains are
insulated by the effects of trauma we
should all care about this because we're
all stakeholders in the education system
we're taxpayers who fund it we're
current or future employers who will
hire the people who graduate from it and
many of us our current and future
parents we're gonna send our kids into
it now if we as the stakeholders exist
in the society that is full of people
who are robbed of their education we
shouldn't be okay with that
now I realized that there's been a lot
of doom and gloom so far and I'm not a
doom and gloom kind of guy I have a lot
of great things to share about three
schools across this country that are
doing meaningful things to address the
impact of trauma the first one is a high
school in Washington State
they've taken an institutional approach
they've put aside the resources to train
teachers to recognize and deal with the
impact of trauma among their students
and hired mental health professionals
on-site what this looks like is when a
student like Sean is acting out in class
his teacher doesn't ask herself
initially what's wrong with Sean but
what happened to him and with that as
the beginning of the conversation
Sean can start a journey of recovery
starting in the classroom and
culminating in the office of that mental
health professional on campus helping
him get through what he's experienced
another great example is the elementary
school in Texas called
Momentis institute they've addressed one
particular symptom of childhood trauma
which is the inability to regulate your
emotions the way they've done that is
they've turned to a trusty glitter ball
they've given every single student a
plastic ball filled with water and
glitter and it holds the key to teaching
students like Shawn how to overcome his
lack of emotional regulation because
when he gets upset or angry he's trained
to first shake up that glitter ball and
not respond to his emotion as the
glitter glitter swirls around inside the
ball Shawn thinks about what he's
feeling and what the most productive way
to respond to that is once that glitter
has settled so is he and over the course
of years he learns how to overcome the
emotions he's experiencing and every day
that might have been lost to emotions
that are out of control
are reclaimed by Shawn the final example
is being developed right here at
Stanford GSB it's called mindful k12 and
it's an app that allows a high school
teacher to start a day with a
mindfulness exercise now in addition to
all of the wonderful benefits of
mindfulness this activity done on the
phones of students culminates in one
question what emotion do you feel most
this morning the result is a roster for
the teacher every student and every
emotion so that when Shawn has his head
on his desk in the back of the classroom
his teacher knows that he reported
feeling really sad this morning and
instead of telling him to shape up she
can walk beside him ask what happened
and reclaim one more day of Shawn's
education our education system may have
a cancer but it's not a death sentence
there are meaningful things that schools
across this country are doing to help
students like Shawn overcome the impact
of their trauma if we as the
stakeholders in the education system can
help these schools set aside the
resources necessary to value their
students mental health as much as their
test scores then we could see some
dramatic improvement if all of us as the
stakeholders can redefine how we
consider quality
then maybe we can help you have sean's
and people like him all around this
country their education back thank you